lanier uh your opponent played a very
unusual opening in this level not not
seen too often were you surprised by it
yeah i was surprised but uh i mean i
more or less i knew that uh
he will play something that will be a
surprise for me so
uh in that sense i was kind of expecting
that that situation and
uh then it was very interesting i think
i played b3 which is very concrete move
i want to play bishop with rook a1 and
so on
and it got complicated i think i was
better
probably i had a big advantage at some
point or when i played when i took one
f6 and played queen c5 but uh
i was long time and i i couldn't find
the best moves probably lanier if i can
ask you and i draw your attention to the
monitor here
um
at this moment you just mentioned the
move b2b3 that you played something very
concrete i think we were expecting
d2d3 when did your
preparation end
i mean i i sort of knew that this line
is possible but i i didn't
remember especially
has b3 been on your the say chess table
at home
uh b3 it's it's of course a typical idea
here to develop like this but uh i'm not
sure if in this position concretely is
the best way
we were surprised by his decision to go
after your c2 pawn once you played the
move b3 we thought that he was going to
frankly go after your king yeah
rookie a bishop and something of this
nature
was going to be uh yeah i think we have
two here no
and if also knight c4 gf knight c4 i see
and then i can take on the six take on a
four or even take on a sound this knight
a5 ideas this was your intention of how
you were going to meet his well after
bishop b2 i thought bishop a3 he has to
play ah bishop a3 and this was
interesting because uh he's still upon
down but then he gets some play with the
play c5 and tries to to get some
initiative like bishop takes rookie five
queen d3 c5 something like this
even uh sacrificing exchanges yeah
because we should be do it's actually a
nice draw
rook g5 and bishop takes f6 rook g2 king
h1 rook takes f2 i think it's a draw
also a puzzle rush
kind of
thing and this is a draw
okay probably rook g3 wins no
yeah no in any case why can't it go for
this i was planning to go c5 f3 and it's
it's complicated i don't know
right bishops of opposite color games
it can be when it's all about the who
has a safer king but in the game he did
go for the
and it was a very enterprising decision
also that he made because
this game was
what's going on what did you what's your
overall assessment at this point i mean
i thought i was actually close to
winning after queen c5 because there is
this idea to play 95 after king v8 of
course was the main point uh instead of
queen e4 uh if it goes king v8 which is
the normal move yes i have knight e5
knight
e5
it's just very strong
because then d7 falls and
i think we looked at this and then we
need to regrade the one i thought and
then rook takes e5 e5 queen e5
i think this is working quindy one queen
of six you did you should believe in
yourself christian
he gave it up when we showed him
yeah
i said i was one move away from one play
one play one plot
ah so that was sorry if you're like
okay
nice he didn't play king b8 as you say
the normal move
instead he retreated
and you got a position that we were
really struggling with how about you
yourself
yeah i mean i i felt that i should be
much better here
but uh just couldn't find yeah rupert g8
is a very strong month of course it's
the only move i think right he's getting
his
counter play
and you decided to trade queens yes and
you got into this position maybe instead
of c6 you had something more precise oh
geez i
i hit the wrong key i apologize
uh instead of uh
c6
yeah but after c6 what did you expect
instead of c6 no i was actually
expecting c6 but i knew that i mean
basically he has few moves any bishop
move with the same idea where rookie 2
is interesting so i wasn't sure i mean i
was long time i didn't have much time
here to
really calculate but uh
okay yeah but c6 knight c4 takes takes
rookie two of course i had g4 here that
was which i saw but uh i was again very
long time and i thought that the way i
played was also leading to to a nice end
game because i
i thought that i have time to
consolidate with king juan rook f2 and
get my king out
but uh he still has
i think good compensation for for the
pawn so concretely speaking
did you reject rook g for
just a tuition just a feeling yeah or
because of a a certain line that
dissuaded you from it no i mean i saw
maybe he'll play rookie 8 and i didn't
see that then i can play rook d4 uh-huh
and rook g8 then g3 and now my pawn is
protected exactly and i uh suspected
that rook takes g4 fg rook d2h4 has to
be very good for me obviously
you're you you have a wonderful race
whether it be h4 h3 yeah yeah the
it's in your favor for sure so yeah but
maybe a missed opportunity then yeah i
had little time and i i was thinking
that this was also good but
the crazy thing is we asked wesley his
opinion he had finished his game about
this ending and
he didn't cheat he just said the truth i
came in and i saw the engine's
evaluation of zero zero zeros all the
way through
we were kind of surprised because we
thought you were pressing
yeah i
i was thinking
that too but uh yeah but uh
once i had time to
to calculate i mean i didn't see exactly
what to do
exactly
all right well uh tough it's
wesley came in and he said it's so hard
to win games here yeah
these are these championships are tough
and then we've had a round like today
where
you're you're one of the only draws did
you realize that
you
only draws it wait wait kick a guy when
he's done yes exactly exactly
linear this game by fabi your opinion
about the result we all have our opinion
on this one do you feel this one is just
a draw
uh
looks like it shouldn't be enough
because i mean there's no way to to do
anything
unless you take on e6 and then it should
be a draw but
i mean black is still under pressure
okay all right well thank you very much
and get your rest we'll see you tomorrow
thank you
well
good good luck linear